sí
así mostraba su apoyo la vicepresidenta
electa de colombia francia márquez al
candidato de izquierda y ex presidente
brasileño luis ignacio 'lula' da silva
gestos de cariño como besos y abrazos y
alabanzas en twitter 'francia márquez
agradeció a lula el amor por colombia y
su apoyo por conseguir la paz mientras
que lula habló de la necesidad de
combatir el racismo en ambos países el
encuentro fue en sao paulo y allí el
lunes cientos de mujeres racializada se
habían salido a las calles para
protestar por la marginación que
enfrentan lula aventaja al actual
presidente ya ir bolsonaro por más de
dos dígitos y el mayor apoyo es entre
las mujeres algo similar sucedió en las
elecciones de colombia que llevaron a
gustavo petro a la presidencia el
primero de izquierda su vicepresidenta
francia márquez se ha vuelto un
referente global ella mismo lo dijo
antes de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales de colombia en
entrevista exclusiva para france 24
mujeres que ahora están en brásil las
mujeres
disputando a espacios de participación
política me están mirando
la gira de francia- márquez no termina
en brasil le esperan líderes políticos y
sociales latinoamericanos continuará en
chile donde se reunirá con el presidente
gabriel boric para después ir a
argentina y encontrarse con alberto
fernández y concluir en bolivia con el
vicepresidente david choquehuanca
encuentros antes del 7 de agosto cuando
tomará posesión en la vicepresidencia